c'est une ville en grande partie
reconstruite après la seconde guerre
mondiale qui vient d'être inscrite par
l'unesco au patrimoine mondial de
l'humanité
la ville du havre annonce faite à
d'urban cet après-midi en afrique du sud
anor mérignac admise bertieaux devant la
mairie l'un des symboles de
l'architecturé auguste perret on hisse
déjà les nouveaux drapeaux le havre est
reconnue comme une ville symbole du 20e
siècle
c'est en effet grâce à la destruction
massive de la ville en septembre 44 que
père et a pu déployer son architecture
novatrice en béton armé sur un terrain
de 130 hectares situation de table rase
j'ai consulté tu déjà vu quelque chose
du représentatif par rapport à ce qui
s'est passé pour un grand nombre d'idées
européenne et surtout que sur cette
table rase moderne
c'est probablement la ville va plus me
parler d'europe construite période après
brasilia le havre est la deuxième ville
moderne classé à l'unesco
longtemps décrié la ville de perret va
acquérir une nouvelle notoriété à
l'office du tourisme les brochures sont
déjà prêtes les touristes étrangers ne
représentent aujourd'hui que 30 % des
visiteurs cela va changer
si on prend par exemple
la clientèle japonaise par exemple c'est
une clientèle qui organise des circuits
sur des sites classés au patrimoine
mondial de l'humanité
donc vous pensez bien que nous allons
appeler tout de suite nos collègues qui
sont au japon pour à leur annoncer la
bonne nouvelle
il eût havre a plusieurs atouts car à
préférer d'autres grands noms de
l'architecturé ont marqué la ville oscar
niemeier guy l'agneau et bientôt jean
nouvel